[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy we find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler today we're going
to talk about stoicon and gathering now
if you thought that i misspoke just now
when i said stoicon
instead of stoicism i i'm not
actually it's they're connected but
they're two different things
and
as we're we're recording this and as
you're hearing it it's a little bit too
late for stoicon 2021 to go to the event
but we're we're going to tell you about
all the different cool ways that you can
still
get in on it and what a stoichon
actually is or what it what it would be
and there's there's not just stoicons
right there's also
stoichon x's and there's stoic weak and
at this point you may be a little bit
inundated with stoic sounding things so
what should we talk about first dan
well we will get to all those lovely
events that are happening over the
course of this month here
but
the whole reason why we even have these
in the first place is this kind of idea
of a pro social um mindset that you find
within so system
and just kind of like to kick us off
i'll bring in a quote from uh seneca the
younger who's
one of the the three big you know
ancient uh stoke writers
and he's writing this um
thing i believe to uh the emperor nero
on clemency and how to kind of like be
be
nice but he's talking it didn't really
stick unfortunately right yeah um and it
it definitely stuck uh
you know seneca in the end yeah that's
true
we could talk about we can tell that
story if people want to hear it i guess
yeah quickly well so seneca
you know he
he wound up being
one of those people who was very
successful but you might say in the
wrong way
so
he gets brought back from exile and
exile was no fun back then um and one of
the one of the conditions was he had to
be the tutor to this young
soon-to-be emperor nero and nobody knew
at that time how bad nero was going to
be he just seemed like kind of a
screw-up and you know maybe you could
work with him and as it turned out he
was he was much worse than anybody ever
figured him for being and seneca you're
right seneca wrote this this work on
clemency he wrote a couple other ones
like on anger to nero trying to provide
him guidance
it looks like nero managed to snow
everybody and none of this advice
actually stuck but we've got these great
works that that represent what seneca
would you know his advice to a
reasonable person
which nero was not and then you know uh
later on seneca tried to extricate
himself from nero's court and it's like
that that line is that is it in the
godfather what it was goodfellas maybe i
keep trying to get out and they keep
pulling me back in which which one was
that do you remember which movie
it was one of those want to say good
fellows but
it's they kind of meld together over the
years yeah so it was that sort of
situation seneca couldn't get away from
it and then there was a plot against
nero and as it turned out a lot of
stoics were indeed involved and that
seneca wasn't but
nero
put them all into one big group and said
seneca you're gonna have to kill
yourself and you might say well why
would you kill yourself just because
somebody else tells you to and the
answer is because if seneca didn't do
that
then you know nero would have killed
everybody else close to him as well
so
that it was bad end for for poor seneca
unfortunately but he got to live pretty
old so yeah
yeah and thankfully we still have his
writings
yeah so so
don't let me hold speaking of
so um in
uh on clemency he is speaking about
stoicism in regard to community and he
says quote
no school has more goodness and
gentleness that has more love for human
beings nor more attention to the common
good the goal which it assigns to us is
to be useful to help others to take care
not only of ourselves but of everyone in
general and of each one in particular
that's a lot of stuff yeah yeah
and and this is kind of like very much
in contrast to what we are usually given
about like you know stoses and kind of
like like a lot of the
the first or the early things that
people are are usually taught about it
is something that's very like insular or
talking about like the your inner
desires and your inner judgments yeah
and how to change those and
um and we often especially if you're
only skimming over the texts you can
miss that the whole point of these
things are actually to you know become a
a better person to be a
a paragon a person of virtue to live in
accordance with virtue and because we
are
these social creatures and
ethics kind of a revolves around this
idea
of how one treats others that that is
really the core of stoicism yeah just
how you get to the point where you can
actually treat others well is sometimes
what is
often
predicated by inner working
you know and i'll i'll admit that when i
was young and i read epictetus and
caridian and then marcus aurelius's
meditations when i was a college student
i was one of those people who only took
from it the parts i was paying attention
to i and i think when it came to all
these um and i like this term that
you're using pro social
not just social but but pro social
valuing that valuing all these things
that seneca
talks about you know goodness love
common good being useful all that i i
kind of think i i treated that like
window dressing like ah he doesn't
really mean this stuff
you know let's get to the real stoicism
things which are what you were talking
about you know withdraw be tough you
know harden yourself against misfortune
and
that led me to
there were two things that came from
that one was it led me to um take on an
idea of stoicism that was a wrong-headed
idea
and then
because there wasn't any really deep
root there
i kind of left it behind until
um
a decade later
and when i when i actually started
reading epictetus in a in a serious way
so misunderstanding things
doesn't give you a stoicism that you can
really use effectively you know
right it's it's a series of tools that
point in time but without like the
proper ends in mind like what are you
actually trying to use these for yeah
you could probably use a lot of these
tools for lots of different ends but you
know not to uh call you a sophist or
anything but like
you can call me a selfish if you want to
it's not going to hurt my feelings
at the time you're using these four ends
that are not exactly the
the things that were prescribed within
the
uh
in the philosophy you're using the
fruits of this philosophy um to to gain
uh ends that are you know potentially
selfish
you know it's interesting that you bring
that up because i think a lot of people
get interested in and attracted to
stoicism these days because they've
they've run across some sort of popular
author who attributes what's going good
for them or you know the kind of work
that they do to stoicism
and it's it's it's often like a kind of
um superficial or you could say just
partial treatment so like the idea that
well you should do stoicism because
that's going to make you resilient and
then you won't complain as much at work
about the bad work conditions
okay stoicism can help you with that but
that's not stoicism right that's that's
that's being used for a different end
then that's just pure resiliency yeah
exactly and then the stoic and there
would be like well how can you make your
uh workplace not as bad as it is like
what are the things you can
pro-socially do you know you can resist
the badness but also you you have to
place some sort of you know virtuous or
good uh ends in that place yeah so when
when we have those kinds of
and i you know we've talked in the past
about like lower case stoicism and and
uppercase estosism i would say that this
is something in between you know
and it's it's not quite
just a caricature
it is based to some degree in in you
know reading seneca or reading marcus
aurelius but it's it's um it's missing
something so like you know if you're if
your stoicism is being studied
so that you can um you know be a more
productive worker
or your
your sports team can you know
hold together better or something like
that that's not a bad thing i mean those
are good things but you're you're
missing out on something and i my
personal hope is that the people that
are attracted to
um stoicism through like tim ferriss or
ryan holiday or any of these these
authors where
the commitment is is um
not as deep let's say some other authors
that these are gateways and they they
they go on and study and learn more and
then they get to appreciate um what
stoicism actually does have to offer to
them
so you know off of
finn we see that people have these they
find these inward things that allow them
to become more resilient in this really
stoic capitalist sense yeah um
uh but you know these um
the whole point is that these inward
things are supposed to allow us to do
those outward actions that are actually
pro-social and so here's a yeah a quote
from mistonius rufus the
teacher of epictetus
and
you will earn the respect of all if you
begin by earning the respect yourself
don't expect to encourage good deeds and
people conscious of your own misdeeds
i mean in a way couldn't that become
discouraging like you let's say you you
approach stoicism the way that most of
us do is kind of screw-ups and you're
like well stoicism is going to help me
be less of a screw-up
and i already know a lot of people who
know me as a screw-up
so they're you know they're conscious of
my misdeeds my co-workers or you know
fellow students or whatever family
members
um
if you follow this
and i i think that i'm sort of playing
devil's advocate here isn't there is
there a risk that
um
you would you know people would just
kind of like brush you off and say oh
you're you're still the same screw up as
you were
i guess my
response would be like if you are
actually
working on yourself then your actions
are going to be following your current
set of beliefs and the things that
you're doing and over time people are
going to actually see that
um you know and you're always going to
run into people that you haven't seen in
a very long time and they'll have this
this weird
like association with you like they know
you
you might have a lot of history with
them but you are no longer
that person yeah
i've definitely found this from like
people that i i've
like i knew in high school but i haven't
like really hung out with in like a
decade or more and so that we all have
these like ideas of what this person is
and that's it's related but it's not
quite the same thing yeah i
i published a book in 2011 and it was
the fruit of like eight years work and
it's you know it's a very scholarly book
it's it's not
um intended to be a popular work and
it's about a kind of obscure topic
and
i was posting about it on facebook and
at that time i was connected with um
the principal of my former high school
catholic memorial high school in
waukesha
and he wrote me back and he said i
remember you
and you don't seem like the sort of
person who'd ever have written a book
let alone a book in philosophy
and i thought that was you know kind of
a nice endorsement um
about you know how i how i changed but
he was very surprised you know it came
out of the blue for him but so if we if
we think about that so this affects
the first part of that passage you will
earn the respect of all if you begin by
earning
the respect of yourself it's not it's
not kind of
pull yourself up by your bootstraps look
in the mirror and
say things like i respect myself
to myself right it's because he's
talking about good deeds so
how do you earn the respect of yourself
is good deeds how you do it
uh i guess within
uh stoicism that thing which is the
actual good are ones
uh
thoughts actions like this
i guess desires and aversions and
actions
um i don't want to get into like too
much to the weeds yeah
i i my brain
presented me lots of ideas i'm like nope
that's a bad idea
yeah so
all of those then could be ways in which
you
earn the respect of yourself i mean it's
kind of it it's it's interesting to talk
about earning your own respect right
can't you just pay it to yourself
automatically or aren't that yeah i mean
somebody could say what are you doing
dummy you're you're making yourself jump
through all these hoops you're the only
person who's actually
looking at it why don't you just uh it's
sort of like you know cheating in a game
right why are you going on all these
quests or doing all this stuff just use
the cheat codes
uh because
it's it's partly the journey and and at
least from my
experience of of working through some of
these core
uh values and these practices i've i've
gained
a
level of you know
tranquility or equanimity that i
definitely hadn't ever had before and
once you
realize that
things that in the past would have
really set you off no longer that is a
a feeling
of kind of like pure joy
i i couldn't relate to that um
i mean i've you know this from our many
conversations that one of the reasons i
got into studying stoicism in the first
place was anger management because i had
a lot of
issues with that it's not you know
completely perfect at this point in time
but i can look back and say wow there's
a lot of things
where
i would have gotten very angry at this
and probably have said something that
you know derailed a conversation or
destroyed a friendship or cr you know
wrecked a business opportunity and and i
don't i don't do that anymore you know
um
[Music]
and it you're right there there's a
dealing with an emotion and it could be
it could be anxiety it could be um
aversion to things it could be
all sorts of negative emotions envy
right that's another big one that holds
people back
realizing that you're free of that and
that you because the progress that
you've made bit by bit you don't have to
feel that over and over and over again
you're not stuck in that anymore it does
produce another emotion that you
described as joy and i think that's
that's a really great
way to talk about it for some people it
might be you know just relief oh man
thanks i don't have to do that now but
but there's something more positive to
that and it could also produce like you
know gratitude
um
and a wish to give back you know a
feeling like wow this helped me
um i bet it could help other people you
know
which would also tie in with the
pro-social stuff that you're talking
about
right
and
yeah
i i could also going back to this quote
like uh
the second half don't expect to
encourage good deeds and people
conscious of your own misdeeds
yeah
um
i don't know i feel like every
everything has to have like a half-life
sometimes like you think about your on
your credit score after seven years it
drops off you know yeah yeah so so mis
so at least some misdeeds
yeah they you should at a certain point
be freed of those and it's interesting
because in a lot of situations people
hold on to those things for decades
you know especially like in family
situations
and and for some people like one of the
things that says it talks about is that
your reputation isn't under your total
control
and
for some people
once you have shown
that you are
changing that you are no longer doing
these misdeeds and that you are doing
things that are actually pro-social yeah
um they will change their their idea
your
idea of what how they respect you
and your reputation goes up but not for
everyone and that's okay because these
things are outside our control yeah
uh
go ahead so just want to kind of move on
a little bit and and kind of like bring
in a little bit more of like why
the the stokes kind of think about these
things and and so the stoics think
that
there are certain things that are
uh
goods and everything else are kind of
indifference
and and one of the things here is you
know our desire anyone that like desires
money as like that ultimate goal this
kind of avarice
um
will will
oftentimes destroy others in order to
gain that maybe even like destroy the
relationships with a family if they
consider that money is the highest good
then they will
potentially sacrifice anything in order
to get that
and
we
as we're talking about stokes and the
thing that is actually good is our
actions
and if those actions are actually you
know wise temperate courageous
and just
if we're doing these things we are no
longer
doing virtuous actions and so
putting these material things or these
things that potentially give us pleasure
over you know being these cardinal
virtues
then we are making a mistake within
stoke philosophy yeah you know epictetus
has a chapter in the discourses where he
talks about
somebody and their fears of poverty of
becoming destitute
and he says
well what is it you're really afraid of
are you afraid like you're not going to
have anything to eat because you can buy
food pretty cheap you just can't you
can't buy the fancy stuff that you like
that you're accustomed to
so you know in our days we talk about
like making beans and rice or ramen or
stuff like that i mean
not the healthiest thing of course and
we could have a whole conversation about
you know food scarcity and deserts but
epictetus point is pretty good you don't
you don't need a ton of money in order
to
you know clothe yourself feed yourself
get water
go from place to place
it's it's wanting to do it in a certain
way and then he and then he turns it on
the person and he says you know what
you're really afraid of and he must have
known this person you're really afraid
of like what other people are going to
say about you
you're worried you're less worried about
actually being poor and you're you're
more worried about like looking poor or
being talked about as poor
and you know and that's not actually a
bad
yeah i mean what's what's the worst that
can happen so people don't invite you to
their parties anymore well you you can't
bring anything to the party anyway
because you're you're
you've got nothing to bring
um
you've got time to do do other stuff
then and and i think that could so
there's the positive things are viewed
as positive things i want to i want to
have a ton of money so i need to
sell out this and sell out this and then
there's the
avoidances you know the aversion to
being in a bad situation
and he talks about that with um
well death of course but also disease
um poverty
um
i suppose we could extend this to like
good looks
reputation you know the loss of those
things can be very
very scary for a lot of people
um position
yeah that's true yeah or even you know
like you think about the people who
retire
and
they've really sunk a lot of themself in
their their job or they lose their job
you know because of economic
dislocations or downsizing and they've
they've placed a lot of their
value how they view themselves as
valuable in that and then once it's
taken away
you know they're really
hurting
oh
i wrote a paper about this once oh yeah
what was it what was it saying
uh
basically that it's on modern stockism
um and it's i think i called it the
locust of meaning oh right yeah yeah
so that is same basically so that is in
the stoicism today blog which you can
find on the modern
site and you know we want to give you
uh the actual site so it's modern
stoicism all one word
dot org i think right
right
um but
very similar um that
if you place your meaning at the thing
that like defines you in these things
that can be taken away from you then uh
when they are taken away then you're
thrown into like a crisis of meaning and
if you kind of like along with stoicism
where we were kind of retreating to the
things that are totally within our
control if you can
retreat your meaning to something that
is also totally in your control then any
you know potential minor external loss
of of something isn't going to actually
cause you that
crisis of meaning yeah i mean it might
still hurt but it's not going to hurt as
much at least
you know
and you have a footing to go forward
with
yeah
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
i mean
and i think that's a significant
difference
our lives don't have to be
made perfect by some philosophy of life
or intentional way of living in order
for us to have significant improvement
in in our lives
right it's it's
we talk a lot about the uh the sage
within stoicism and that's kind of like
this you know
uh north star it's it's a a goal to
aspire to
but any any progress from where you are
to that place even if you never get to
that place are
uh have benefits in and of themselves
yeah so there's
there's no
and value
you know um
i think a lot of people there's a
there's a perfectionism that easily gets
in any sort of um
way of you know self-improvement
any
bit of improvement that you make even if
it doesn't like automatically change
people's views on you or you still screw
up or
um it doesn't
work in every situation it's still
something real it's still improvement
yeah
so um you know
greg why do we gather
together as humans
that's a big question i mean i think
there's i think there's a lot of uh
reasons some of it i think has to do
with our our kind of animality um
and it it probably isn't just a
distinctively human thing i mean you
think about like
cuddling together between animals who
who are different species right um like
you know we have we have a cat now who's
the only one left of our four-legged
family but she and her sister got
adopted by my wife before my wife
adopted these two big dogs and the cats
got to set the agenda and the tone you
know they're much they were much smaller
than the dogs but you know when the dogs
were puppies they the cats
induced in them the proper respect for
cats right and you know they would
they'd all like cuddle together and hang
out together and every once in a while
one of them would
you know be mean to the other one um as
a matter of fact one of the things that
really soured the relationship between
the the the one surviving cat and the
one surviving dog was when the cat
started
deliberately standing up on her hind
legs and eating out of the dog's bowl
you could see this betrayed look right
so there's there's something on a very
basic level
of gathering
for comfort and
for there's something
there's something in our very nature
i mean the stoics recognize this
um there's there's a uh stoic
uh called heracles who talks about this
process that in greek is called oikiosis
and we often translate it as
appropriation which is a little abstract
but it includes um self-care self-love
sort of a natural thing in born in us
and there's also a natural
tendency not not necessarily to love
everybody but to
for that natural self-affection to reach
out to
things that are like us
and they can be like us in being the
same species they can be like us and
being our family members but they can
also be like us in just having
observable
needs and emotions and
you know cuddling together for closeness
and then you know i mean there's all
sorts of other reasons why we
gather together some of them not so
great i mean we could gather together to
rob somebody
we can gather together to benefit people
um you know think about jimmy carter
who's still out there i guess he's 97
now
building houses with habitat for
humanity that's a gathering process
right
all right and then there's a there's a
point to it so there's all sorts of
reasons for for gathering um
what were you thinking what did you have
in mind oh
i've got a number of things you know
uh and i was kind of thinking like
specifically why are we gathering for
what we're about to talk about in just a
moment with uh stoicon okay and you know
we have these things but we also we
gather or to
build up big things we gather to
uh provide like safety and protection
for each other but we also gather to
share information and share goods and
share stories you know just think about
like you know you got a couple of people
wandering through the wilderness you
have a fire and you sit down you share
stories like why not like like what does
it cost you it costs you nothing it's
free to give and
that's true yeah um you know and when it
comes to
cons which are
conventions or conferences
um i mean you know it's interesting like
academic conferences
sometimes you go to them because you're
expected to do that as part of your your
work you have to present papers
or you have to like do job interviews at
them that used to be the way it went and
people would be like oh i have to go to
philadelphia for another you know
stupid conference and it might come like
a really inopportune time
but i mean there's other reasons to go
to conferences um getting to see people
that you would like to get to know you
know like academic superstars
i i ran into quite a few of them at
conferences
um or you know you get to know people
over time and you're like well i'll see
you next year at the conference
and you have something in common it's
cool to be with people who share
interests with you especially if you you
know if you're kind of isolated like
when i was teaching
at indiana state prison when i first
began
as an assistant professor
um you know i liked the guys who i was
teaching but i was just so starved for
pure contact you know the guys would be
interested saying the stoics or
aristotle
but i couldn't talk with them
like as you know peer-to-peer with
somebody else who had been studying
those things and it could be anything it
could be like you know fishing lures it
could be
um comic-con coming up or or you know
like
when we have i'm kind of gesturing to uh
the the wisconsin center that's only
blocks from from us like when they have
that that midwest auto show right and
all all the gearheads show up
and they're they're they're into it they
think it's really cool right
um so i think that's that's an important
aspect of it getting to
spend time with people who
value what you value
right it kind of reminds me of
when you go to college and you now have
thousands of people and there's a group
for everything and you can find those
people that are like right on your
wavelength or into all the same things
that you are
and you know you're moved away from like
your high school where you've got like
you know
yeah yeah there's only so many people
around and and maybe one other person
has at least some passing similar
interests that you do and now you're
like i found my people
you know and if you're going to a place
that's a professional school so like you
know milwaukee institute of art and
design here in milwaukee
or berkeley school of music out in
boston or the culinary institute of
america in hyde park
very often you you were that one person
who was who was into this and good at
that you knew a few people and now
suddenly you're in a whole school that's
devoted to that
you know for for some people it can be
disconcerting because they go from being
the proverbial big fish in a small pond
to being just one more person who's into
art or music or cooking um but but most
people respond very positively to that
so i wanted to say like you know once
again the stokes talk about us
like trying to do things are pro-social
because we're social creatures yeah kind
of like the the basis of that is like
the stoic ethics and
um we we talk about pro-social things
under like the heading of justice
what is the just way that one acts and
interacts with other people
and um you know without other you know
creatures other people for us to
actually interact with
then like a lot of the ethics kind of
goes out the window that's right yeah
and so i get like question i want to ask
you was oh if there was no one
out there to interact with
are there still ethical decisions to be
made yeah you mean like um if you were
the proverbial last man on earth right
right
i think that there's also no like um
no aliens no
no and no like a higher life forms
greater than bacterium oh okay wow
that's that's so no cats no dogs not
even spiders you know i'm right i kind
of like spiders myself but
um i would say yes but it's in an
attenuated attenuated way right so
you can't be
just in relation to any other people
because there's no people
i mean you could say well what about
people in the past like you know you
save their books and stuff like that
well they wouldn't really care from a
stoic perspective they're gone you know
but you could still be temperate you
know you could i mean
if you were the last person on earth one
of the temptations would be let's go get
as drunk as possible because you know i
can't stand this solitude and you know
i'll eat anything that i want because
you know who cares how fat i get or out
of shape
temperance would help you to not do that
and you might still need you might still
need courage
um i mean you're not facing like you
know saber-toothed tigers or anything
like that but you would use the stoic
virtue of courage involves like
perseverance so
and not not despairing too um
wisdom you'd still need that
justice i i i don't think i don't think
that would exist if there aren't other
people
um i mean it's not as if just it's not
as if justice goes away right because
potentially
maybe you could clone yourself or you
run into somebody else and now justice
could exist in the world you just
couldn't
you couldn't make it actual
without another person is there any
justice towards oneself
um that's a good question
in in the stoic scheme right
um
i mean i guess if you made a promise to
yourself that you kept it
as opposed to breaking it but i i don't
know
what do you think
i i'm of the opinion that there's you
can still make just
decisions in regard to yourself okay
it's your future self
oh your future self okay how what would
that look like
uh as you said like you made a promise
that you're going to like you know do
something tomorrow and like i i've now
made you know some sort of contract with
myself that like you know i'm i'm
intending to do this okay then you're
like who is holding my me to this it is
just me yeah yeah but
but then i look about that about like my
everyday things and i do set out goals
for myself and i try to
uh
achieve them as much as i can
um and so i guess
i see that even in
you know living with other people that i
do have a justice to myself when i am
making these obligations to myself
do you think that's justice or do you
think that falls more under
courage with like perseverance and
you know following through on what is
what is difficult
or is it both maybe i i think it's both
i i just like think about like you know
if i were to treat another person say
like i'm going to do this for you yeah
tomorrow
um it's very
very similar to i'm going to do this for
myself tomorrow
i think i may have told you about a gym
coach that i had when i was
in high school who made a big impression
on me like a lifelong impression on me
um he scared the hell out of all of us
the very first day of class and
apparently i'll tell you this and then
i'll tell you the the the actual point
the first day of class he lined us up in
the bleachers and he was shouting at us
i guess there had been a problem the
previous year with guys essentially
engaging in acts of sexual harassment
against against girls
and he wanted to make sure that we knew
that was not going to be tolerated at
all you know and we were like wow who is
this guy he's very intense but once he
got to know him he was
incredibly fair
and
he followed through on every commitment
that that he made as far as i could ever
see
um and he um he would always say to us
don't cheat yourself whether you were
running or doing some sort of activity
that required skill or lifting weights
it was like his mantra
and at first he'd be like ah that's just
you know some silly slogan but he really
meant it and it stuck with me and when i
go and work out at the gym and i'm
tempted to slack off because i'm on my
third set of 12 and i'm like i don't
need to do 12 i can do 11. i don't
actually like hear the voice in my head
but it
it's there that message don't cheat
yourself it's not don't cheat coach
because he he doesn't you know he's he's
gone right
um he's not dead thank god but um
he's he and i haven't talked for
30 years
but that message don't cheat yourself i
guess that would be like what you're
talking about is justice here
yeah
um
thank you for that
so i guess to go back like why do we
also gather yeah
um you know we talked a little bit about
you know um symposium
are going to symposia uh you know to for
these academic conferences present some
information it might be required of you
but we also have just you know general
um meetings for mutual understandings
like this is you know i guess a little
bit not not quite in the the pop and
circumstance of academia but maybe like
well there's not a lot of pop inside
trust me
i do remember a lot of wine
symposia originally were drinking
parties right that's that's what the
word means and and uh
quite a few of them in ancient times
were
philosophical but they still got pretty
hammered
right
um i just remember going to a lot of
physics symposia in college and those
were
entertaining and they like to party
oh yeah
that's great especially the um the
plasma physics students that they're
like stuck there for like six years a
minimum on their graduate work because
their uh experiments take so long yeah
and so like they know how to like pass
the time that's good you know i mean so
again so long as it's temperate right
right right which doesn't mean that you
never you never indulge yourself but you
you know you do so within limits
um
but let's yeah let's come back to
talking about um
stoicism and stoichon right
so
every year
for the last 10 years
the what's become the modern stoicism
organization
has had a conference and it was
face-to-face for the first uh eight
years
i was able to go to three of them in
recent years and and provide workshops
in
new york city and toronto and london and
those are the main places they've been
held they also did one in athens one
year which would have been kind of cool
to go to but i i didn't i didn't want to
try to you know do that in the middle of
the semester
and then there are these smaller
stoichon x events that are all over the
world that have popped up in like the
last four or five years i'd say
we actually had one here in milwaukee
that both dan and i spoke at
uh two years ago yeah two years ago and
i was in person yeah and then once covid
hit
we had to figure out what to do and
similar to what we're doing here
um you know doing things remotely
stoicon went online and it was really
interesting what happened because
you miss out on some things right you
obviously don't get to hang out with
people
after a talk and like go and have a
conversation with them or have lunch or
dinner or have a drink or stuff like
that or even see them at the airport
but it opened up access to people
all over the world obviously in some
time zones better than others australia
it's kind of difficult to participate in
a new york time event but um
especially if it's an all-day event but
last so in in previous years with
face-to-face
conferences the most we'd ever get in
one room was about 350 or 400 people
tops
last year
[Music]
1400 people registered for stoicon
and i think the most that were ever on
on the zoom call
at one given time were a thousand people
so that's a thousand people listening to
a speaker talk about
some interesting aspect and
communicating with each other in the
chat and you know participating in
something this year we've all it's going
to be held you know shortly um and uh
we've already got a thousand people at
this point and we're probably gonna have
even more people
um
so you know there's that and then we
recorded it and and greg yeah are are
you doing something with stoke on this
year
so
my wife and i andy
uh who are along with dan the uh
co-organizers of the milwaukee stoic
fellowship um
we undertook to become the the
organizers for stoicon itself this year
and in part because a guy who
handled it in the past donald robertson
he's done three of them uh he this year
he was like i don't want to do it again
it's a lot of work um so i i asked andy
and she said yeah let's let's do it so
and we've got we've got other helpers
too um
we have a guy who handles that all the
tech stuff we have um my friend harold
who's doing the lightning round talks
dan is actually participating by being
one of the breakout session leaders for
tim labon's workshop so there's a lot a
lot of people doing things you know
and you know it's it's a great
conference i've always enjoyed going to
it
you meet a lot of people and
there's there's usually really great
talks and this time we made it more
interactive so not only are there talks
you know or somebody gets up and maybe
they have some slides and they go
through their their thing we're also
doing panels where you can ask questions
and we have a workshop and
you know all that sort of
stuff as well to make it really
interactive
um so it's
go ahead
by the time that you know you hear this
if yeah you're not already there
it's probably done
but uh all of the talks will be
on youtube on the modern stoicism
channel um just you know
search for either modern socialism or
stoicon 2021 and that should pull up all
of them it'll it'll be a little while
before they get posted because because
i'm the one who has to do all the
editing but
so
they'll get rolled out bit by bit but
yeah it's it's i mean that's another
kind of cool thing about this doing it
online
means that we have
there's there's a time and place that it
happens right
uh it's a virtual place
but then it kind of exists afterwards a
la carte
you know you can go and be like i want
to hear nancy sherman's keynote address
because i heard that was pretty good you
know or
i want to see what tim lebon was doing
in his workshop or
or uh
what uh aldo dinucci is doing down in
brazil i do believe yeah he's he's a
professor down in brazil he's one of our
our speakers as well
um
so that'll be that'll be quite
interesting um
and we actually have a team too kai
whiting and leonardo's constant tacos
who do some writing together and and
present together
uh
leo by the way just i think just
defended his dissertation
so
he's now
dr leo i think
uh which is which is good for him um so
there's gonna be yeah there's gonna be a
lot of cool stuff
so uh you know i
i see you behind you you've got this
great background of
yeah
the actual stoa that we all talk about
and so um the stoa is a you know a
painted porch or a a big uh covered
colonnade
on and so you know instead of those like
nice bright white marble that you see
behind you in the time that we're
actually talking about this would have
been painted with really bright and
vibrant colors yeah the greeks and the
italians back in the day loved color and
they painted it on everything yeah um
but it's it's a place to together that's
the whole point is you know once again
the the whole
a centerpiece of stoicism is it's not
about a person or their ideas but it was
like how do we define ourselves oh we're
the guys that gather in this place in
the stoa well and originally they
weren't called um
they were they were called zenonians
because you know was teaching there and
then they became the people of the stoa
the stoics right
so yeah
so i just i love that like part of it is
like they'd go there after being in the
gymnasium and i'm like just thinking yo
bro do you even know what the good life
entails
i don't know if everybody wants to
to the gym but yeah certainly some of
them came from there from their jobs in
the marketplace or yeah i mean that's a
good point it provided uh
it provided a center where you could go
and you could know that somebody else
was going to be interested in what you
had to say
or what you wanted to ask them or you
know
the topics that were on your mind i
guess i guess that works for a lot of
other things too right
yeah he's finding these gathering places
and you know uh
fortunate or unfortunate depending on
how you look on it um
you know we are in a time where we have
technology that allows us to gather and
so we have our virtual stellas
yeah and and i i see that as a great
thing as a matter of fact i kind of
think that without the internet and
mobile technology and youtube and
all these things that are you know tied
together and permeate our existence you
you wouldn't see this
um
massive surge of interest in stoicism i
mean there's books right and the books
books are important but
you know it's not as if this is getting
promoted a lot in the traditional media
and it's and it's not really coming that
much out of like you know academics and
the university it's something that gets
its hold through
what the internet has to offer
i mean i i wouldn't know
any of these people who i'm
introducing at the event
if it wasn't well except for
uh
andy um
who i'm married to
uh if if it hadn't been for the internet
you know
so speaking of other things that you can
actually do there are uh there are a
number of stoichon x events uh coming up
that are the these regional things and
some might even have like impersonal
events
but there's also a a whole thing that's
called stoic week which i think is like
the
starts the 18th of october this year
yeah yeah and it runs for an entire week
it is it is a stoic week and what you do
is there's like a handbook that you
download and an online class that you
sign up for it's totally free
and
each day you have like a morning reading
and an evening reading and there's a
practice for the day there's usually
like a theme you know to be doing
something with
and um you keep track of stuff and you
interact with other people who are doing
this class a lot of whom are doing it
for the first time and some of whom are
doing it like it's a tune-up that's the
way i look at my
uh this will be like my
sixth or seventh time going through it
um
and it's it's really helpful um we have
data
tim labon is one of the main researchers
who's been compiling stuff on this for
years we've got data that actually shows
that trying to live like a stoic
in a consistent way for a week
makes your life better it changes your
attitudes about things i mean it's not
gonna like radically
revise your life uh but but it it does
make things better and so it's quite
interesting to to find that out
so a little excerpt from it you can also
find more at uh
modern stoicism dot com slash stoic
stash
week
but
a little
uh preview is like you will learn about
how the ancient philosophy of stoicism
can be adapted to help us lead better
lives the course combines general theory
with more specific step-by-step guidance
on certain stoic exercises these
materials have been prepared by experts
in the field and give you an
unusual and completely free of charge
opportunity for personal development
yeah and this is this is kind of a
a cool and unique thing i mean
over 10 000 people usually these days
participate in the course each year
the numbers have just been going up and
up and up every every year and a lot of
them are first-timers
some people will go through the week
together like some of the
little stoic organizations here and
there will like do it with themselves
there's classes that that do it academic
classes and you know philosophy or
classics or other other related uh
fields like that
and
it would be kind of cool to see
something like this done for other
philosophies of life
you know there could be an epicurus week
or there could be
uh live like a cynic week you know or
an aristotel i don't know
i don't know if anyone can
get through being like a diogenes well
you wouldn't necessarily want to be that
guy right there's other cynics you could
model yourself after
um
but yeah i mean it's it's a i mean if if
you're the kind of person who likes
experimenting
with changing your life and seeing what
that does to you
this would be a really great thing to do
even if you know if you're not
particularly interested in stoicism it
would add one more thing to that list
and if you are interested in stoicism
it's a great way to learn more about it
yeah you actually have a course in which
you
uh sometimes asks your students to uh
try out certain things correct oh you're
talking about my course at milwaukee
institute of art and design yeah i i get
to teach that every three semesters and
it's very popular the students really
enjoy it and it's not just um stoicism
we we usually do like five units so this
last time
we
we started with um
after we do some basic stuff about
mindfulness and you know philosophy is a
way of life and practices
we did the epicurean tradition
we did the utilitarians and effective
altruism
and then we switched to the cynics and
the stoics and then we looked at
in a very selective way buddhism you
know because we've got this vast vast
religious
and philosophical tradition so it was
mostly
looking at some uh theravadin techniques
and then pure land buddhism and
zen buddhism
and then the semester's over but each
week the students would have some
practices that they were supposed to
experiment with and they would keep
records and and sometimes they'd say
well this i didn't like this at all it
just didn't work for me you know
and sometimes they'd be like wow this
really changed my perspective or this
really
helped me with this this issue i suppose
i should probably
do more surveying of them and start
using some more rigorous things to like
see whether
doing this stuff you know say lowers
their anxiety but i just haven't gotten
to that so far i've been just developing
content for them but they really enjoy
it and i think they really enjoy it
because they get to
they don't just learn something they get
to apply it they get to see if it if it
fits into their life
and so here is an opportunity for you to
do at least a fifth of what greg uh has
his students do
um
and and you can spend a week on it like
it is either just a challenge for you to
try something out new or to deepen your
experience of stoicism if you are
interested in it but it's also a a very
large and ongoing social experiment
yeah
that's a good idea gathering
they're gathering data yeah so they they
try to uh send you through a
questionnaire about like how you feel
about kind of life in the general uh
beneficial way that you're looking at
life at the beginning of the week and
then do that again we do a comparison of
over that week
and one of the biggest things the thing
that has repeatedly come up in these is
the thing that is highest correlated to
starting to live this stoic lifestyle is
this feeling of zest or on
a
uh was a
living life with great enthusiasm and
energy
um and so like this is sometimes defined
as like
oh sorry this is sometimes defined um
along the lines of
you know are you looking forward to each
new day do i feel excited about the
upcoming day am i bringing you with
excitement about life um do i try to
live each day to the fullest and things
along those lines
yeah and i was going to say this was a
big surprise to tim labon he actually
reported on it in stowa at the stoicon
2018 which was in london and he got up
there with all his charts and he was
like
so i'm not quite sure how this turn came
out this way but zest was the trait that
you know went up the highest and then he
had to say well that's kind of cool what
what is zest right and it's in some ways
counterintuitive you'd think well stoics
okay practicing this i won't be as
anxious you know i'll feel be more
resilient it's mostly like negative
stuff but zest is very very positive the
way that psychologists construe it and
so this is kind of a cool finding that
doing this stuff will actually make you
feel
happier in your life
yeah
so i think um
to kind of like wrap this up let's talk
about a practice the festival mindset
so um this is a kind of a reframing
technique um of you know think of you
can either go and be out in the the
streets and uh and you can
uh be
bombarded with the cacophony of all the
the noise and the the hustle and bustle
and the the seeming um just randomness
of everything and you can be like
disturbed and annoyed by all these
things around you
yeah
or or you can do something like a
reframing now now instead of like i'm
i'm beset by all these annoyances and
these people and they're getting in my
way but i'm now
at a festival that this is something
that can
uh i'm enjoying the revelry and all
these people are all my guests and i get
to live life and enjoy it with them at
all times
do you want to read that you've got a
great quote from epic yesterday about
this so
when you're alone you should call this
condition tranquility and freedom and
think of yourself like the gods and when
you are with many you shouldn't call it
a crowd or a trouble or uneasiness but
festival and company and contentedly
accept it
that's a nice line do you want to lead
us out as because we're getting close to
time yeah so epictetus is teacher
yes from essonius rufus we leave you in
these words
for mankind evil is injustice and
cruelty and indifference to a neighbor's
trouble while virtue is brotherly love
and goodness and justice and
magnificence
and concern for the welfare of your
neighbor
[Music]
my
[Music]
you